within the last few minutes uh just
after a vote
uh rejecting calls for a special
committee to be set up
to investigate this scandal comes some
news that
will not please the prime minister the
treasury select committee
one of the top all party select
committees in the house of commons
has announced that it is to launch an
inquiry
into as it puts it the lessons from
green sill capital
this is an all-party select committee
chaired by the former treasury minister
former leader of the commons mel stride
and they have announced uh following a
meeting today
they will launch an inquiry into the
lessons from greensville capital
the committee had agree has agreed in
principle to launch the inquiry and will
officially launch the inquiry
next week at which point it will publish
its full terms of reference
the committee will focus on the
regulatory lessons
from the failure of green sill capital
and
the appropriateness of the treasury's
response
to lobbying in relation to green sale
capital and mel stride the chairman of
the committee said this
the treasury committee had previously
decided to carefully consider
these issues as part of its regular and
upcoming evidence sessions
with the treasury and its associated
bodies including the financial conduct
authority and bank of england in
addition to this
we've now decided to take a closer look
by launching an inquiry to investigate
the issues
that fall within our remit we will
publish further details when we launch
the inquiry
officially next week well the background
to this
is it's been claimed that uh the tory
majority on the committee last week
uh voted against um uh
holding this inquiry and uh clearly
somebody on the committee's had a change
of heart because they've voted to hold
this inquiry
i can bri i can tell you that
this will not please the prime minister
both in prime minister's questions today
uh mr johnson talked about having a
committee of parliament
looking at lobbying of mps and ministers
would be mps
marking their own homework now since the
vote in the commons and we've just heard
the numbers
95 government majority 3 five
seven to two six two um uh
the uh shadow cabinet office minister
rachel reeves has said in response to a
conservative mps voting against the
labor motion for a parliamentary
inquiry boris johnson's mps have voted
to cover up cronyism it is the return of
tory sleaze
afraid phrase we heard from sarkistarma
one rule for them she says another for
everybody else labor will keep standing
up for the british people
so we can end this culture of
conservative cronyism now this was
rachel reid
reid reeves a little earlier opening the
debate
in the commons which has just concluded
this motion today
does what the government should have
done but chose not to
it gives the power to this house not the
government
with a 16 strong select committee with
clout to investigate this whole
sorry scandal it would have powers to
call witnesses and examine them in
public
like an effective select committee would
the scope of the investigation that we
propose
would look at inappropriate lobbying of
government and what needs to be done
to change and prevent it
so the labour party lost that vote
heavily as was white as of course we
knew it would
but this development in the last couple
of minutes is a hugely significant
the treasury committee is going to hold
an inquiry into the lessons from green
sill capital
they will have the power to call the
chancellor rishi sunak
mr cameron and uh no doubt other uh
people involved in this as well other
ministers who've been lobbied the bank
of england
as you've just described mark so
potentially
uh this is going to be a big box office
mr cameron
hauled before a commons committee to
explain when
what went on and the chancellor of the
exchequer also called
to give evidence to this commit this
inquiry that's just been announced
by the treasury select committee and all
party committee of mps